And I say you, Mexico City, the neighborhood,
Merced Balbuena, invented sex, not San
Nicolás, the Orient,
the Mexican art for ever.
and it comes hits pereyra movement
alebrijes of tics help
in the house of America
[Music]
exact and it is an alebrije
[Applause]
an alebrije for me is a
fantastic figure that has to have at least
three elements of earth, water and fire and
not air
[  Music]
of land well you could take a lion of
air you can take a bird
of fire' the bulging eyes the
viperine tongues and sea can you could take
some fins areas crests to be able to more
or less carry a composition of what would
be good for me leonardo  it would be an
alebrije
and not wear them out and not invite back to
one man pedro linares leonardos great
to proceed to tryphon intercom arenal
network schoenberg
clijsters crime t  he world lebrija
[Music]
a delight
norman week of state building
alebrijes
in ships are big on the continent
tradition grandfather I have sometimes the
foreigners that were not sold
to him so he began to modify
them a bit as well, adding color to them,
not making them so terrifying  and my
dad is the one who gives them all the
plasticity of the movement and dad gives them
all the creativity of putting them called
feathers more greg and you are more
bulging eyes tablecloths more crests that is to
make the most harmonious my grandfather and
we I think we never thought about it
that it was going to have an impact and the scope that
the figures
that my grandfather had seen in his comatose state at the time were going to have,
or everything that has been done has always
come from here, that is, first it has been an
inspiration from here and then, well, now
many people already reproduce it because it is
important because it is part of our
normal essence as a country as a people
many times we have been called the
guardians of things to  yes that of popular art
[Music]